so excuse me one second hello oh gee I
can't talk right now why don't you give
me your home number and I'll call you
later
oh I guess you don't want people calling
you at home well now you know how I feel
what are you saying
not saying anything you're saying
something what could I be saying well
you're not saying nothing you must be
saying something why don't you say I
said it
sixty-six years old well he's in perfect
health
he works out he's vibrant you'd really
like why did he call I say that I hate
everybody why would I like him 66 year
old woman oh yeah she would have to be
really vibrant so vibrant she'd be
spinning oh sorry we have no mid-sized
available at the moment I don't
understand I made a reservation do you
have my reservation yes we do
unfortunately we ran out of cars but the
reservation keeps the car here that's
why you have the reservation I know why
we have reservations I don't think you
do if you did I'd have a car so you know
how to take the reservation you just
don't know how to hold and that's really
the most important part of the
reservation the holding anybody can just
take it it's come to my attention that
you and the cleaning woman have engaged
in sexual intercourse on the desk in
your office
is that correct who said that she did
was that wrong I tell you I got a plead
ignorance on this thing because if
anyone had said anything to me at all
when I first started here that that sort
of thing was frowned upon
you know cuz I've worked in a lot of
offices and kotaki of people do that all
the time you're fired you have a little
something on your face I can get it
Nana Nana you're missing it it's higher
let's make a wish I don't want to make a
wish okay come true don't you just love
Lobster
[Music]
there you go Merry Christmas
mail on Sunday oops what's the deal with
lampshades yeah I mean if it's a lamp
why do you want shade
[Laughter]
and what's with people getting sick yeah
I mean what's the deal with cancer I
have cancer
Oh tough crowd
[Music]
oh my god this is the baby's room I'm
really sorry
I was on the ball I was on the ball
would you like to come upstairs for some
coffee
well no thanks I can't recall feel it at
night it keeps me up I just threw away a
lifetime of guilt-free sex and floor
seats for every sporting event in
Madison Square Garden
so please a little respect
for I am Costanza Lord of the idiots
[Applause]
but suddenly a new contender has a no
you're proposing a snow tire day at
Yankee Stadium they don't throw a letter
field
help yourself to some [ __ ] I brought it
up bourbon I have to say this this
proposal doesn't make a whole lot of
sense well you never know
let's see how many I can fit my mouth
you know George the ocean called they're
running out of shrimp
well the jerk star called they're
running out of you what's the difference
you're their all-time bestseller
[Laughter]
well I had sex with your wife
[Applause]
his wife is in a coma